[Aplausos]
hace 7 años estudiaba yo la carrera de
derecho y me invitaron a formar parte de
un proyecto de la sociedad de alumnos la
idea era ir a la asesoría jurídica
personas privadas de la libertad en
cárceles del estado de mexico
en ese entonces quería ser abogada
penalista así que sin pensarlo dos veces
dije que sí
se podrán imaginar que el paso 1 era
entrar a los penales el primero de ellos
fue variantes
detrás de las rejas y después de varios
filtros de seguridad llegamos al espacio
donde nos esperaban los rostros las
historias de las personas que detrás de
cuatro paredes grises han sido apartadas
de la sociedad
ay conoce a fabiola
fabiola se convirtió en mamá cuando
tenía tan solo 14 años
su hijo ya joven conoció las drogas en
la calle para apagar su visión recurrió
a la delincuencia hasta que fue detenido
fue llevado preso a la sección varonil
de barrientos y allí fabiola lo visitaba
todos los fines de semana ella plancha
la ropa para ganar dinero pero se podrán
imaginar que ese dinero nunca era
suficiente para mantenerse a ella y
mantener a su hijo dentro de prisión
entonces un día de visita como cualquier
otro a la entrada del reclusorio se le
acercó una persona
y le ofreció una buena cantidad de
dinero si ella de contrabando metía un
poco de droga para entregárselo a un
interno
ante la necesidad se le hizo fácil
y tuvo suerte las primeras dos veces
pero la tercera un custodio la descubrió
y fue así como fabiola pasó seis años en
prisión
conocí también la historia de jennifer
una niña de apenas 18 años que
desafortunadamente había sido maltratada
y abusada sexualmente por su padrastro
desde que ella era muy chica le contó a
su mamá pero nunca le creyó
y además tenía una hermana menor que un
día llorando le confesó como este señor
también había empezado a molestarla a
ella
una tarde de regreso de la escuela entró
a su casa descubrió este señor
intentando violar a su hermana
ella reaccionó y lo único que alcanzo a
ver fue el machete de su abuelo en la
entrada lo tomo y recuerdo como en
prisión me contaba y me decía te juro no
no sé qué me pasó pero es que sentía
tanta rabia que ya no pude parar
conocí a hacer muchas otras historias
como la de fabiola o la de jennifer y
cada que entrábamos y salíamos de la
cárcel de regreso en el camión hacia la
universidad volteaba la ventana y era
para mí inevitable preguntarme por qué
ellas por qué no yo
y descubrí
que había muchas cosas que yo no sabía
la primera es que a veces lo que hemos
diferenciado de las personas que estaban
ahí dentro eran tan solo en las
circunstancias en las que habíamos
nacido en las que habíamos crecido
circunstancias que ni fabiola guillén
ife ni yo habíamos elegido
muchas de ellas habían tenido que dejar
la escuela desde muy pequeñas por falta
de dinero
otras nunca conocieron una muestra de
cariño de amor de parte de su mamá o de
su papá muchas vivían en esquemas en
donde no existían reglas nunca les
fijaron límites no había estructura no
habían figuras de autoridad
no sabía porque había gente que decía
que la cárcel es solo para los pobres
hasta que lo vi un poco más tarde lo
comprobé con las cifras 230 mil personas
están privadas de la libertad de nuestro
país de ella 66 por ciento provienen de
hogares en condiciones de pobreza 70% si
bien les fue terminan de estudiar tan
solo hasta la secundaria y 40% como en
el caso de fabiola dejaron la escuela
desde muy chicas por falta de dinero de
sus casas
no sabía tampoco que las cárceles en
nuestro país son como esta especie de
micro entorno de microcosmos en donde se
replican todos esos problemas
estructurales que decimos que queremos
combatir la desigualdad la falta de
oportunidades los estereotipos de género
esta reproducción de los círculos de
violencia lo inhumano que puede llegar a
ser una autoridad y desde luego la
corrupción la corrupción sistémica que
garantiza el que más dinero tiene
mayores privilegios porque desde luego
no sabía que dentro de la cárcel todo
créanme todo cuesta
tener agua potable bañarse con agua
caliente comer algo decente recibir
visitas cambiar de celda incluso comprar
productos de higiene básicas poder
comprar un papel de baño toallas
sanitarias una pasta de dientes cuesta
más caro de lo que nos cuesta que afuera
se dice que aproximadamente cinco mil
pesos mensuales podría llegar a gastar
una persona privada de la libertad para
subsistir mínimamente ahí dentro
y quizás yo no sabía nada de esto porque
a ver aceptémoslo como sociedad nos han
convencido que la cárcel y el castigo es
la solución a esta inseguridad que nos
golpea a diario todas nuestras
conversaciones nuestros chats las redes
sociales están llenas de anécdotas de
víctimas de la violencia y de la
delincuencia
y es justamente por eso que me empecé a
cuestionar si la cárcel servía realmente
para ello
fue así como nosotros conociendo estas
historias
yo pensaba un poco igual
hasta que tuve la oportunidad de entrar
a la cárcel y de conocer historias de
mujeres que desde muy pequeñas estaban
ligadas en entornos de mucha violencia
muchas dependían de una manera terrible
económica y psicológicamente a hombres
que al final en el caso de fabiola
resultaron ser la causa por la cual
habían decidido cometer un delito
conocí también muchas historias de
injusticias y entonces entendí
que detrás de cada uniforme beige que es
el que les ponen cuando están
sentenciadas o de cada uniforme azul
cuando están procesadas existe mucho más
pero mucho más que sólo una causa penal
o el nombre de un delito
entendimos que pues obviamente no iba a
pasar solo la ayuda jurídica porque
eventualmente estas mujeres iban a salir
a las mismas circunstancias al mismo
entorno que había hecho propicio la
comisión del delito
lo que necesitábamos era darles
herramientas para prepararlas para una
vida fuera de prisión
necesitábamos reducir la posibilidad de
que cuando salieran por su mente pasara
la idea de volver a cometer un delito
y descubrimos que había muchísimo
talento
muchos de ellos no sabían tejero ya
sabían bordar
y entonces nos dimos cuenta que sólo era
cuestión de perfeccionar está técnica
para que pudieran generar algún producto
que se pudiera vender y pudiera competir
como cualquier otro
fuera de prisión
y así fue como surgió la cama para los
que no saben a la cana se le conoce
coloquialmente ahí dentro es como decir
el bote y lo que soy la cana es una
empresa que busca generar un proyecto de
vida distinto
uno que mediante la capacitación y el
trabajo
pueda darles a estas mujeres una
oportunidad para mantenerse ahí dentro
para también poder ser un apoyo
económico para sus familias en el
exterior
y desde luego existe la posibilidad para
que puedan ahorrar para tener dinero una
vez que salen de prisión
esto se dice fácil pero obviamente han
sido tres años de mucho esfuerzo de
mucho aprendizaje y por qué no decirlo
también de uno que otro fracaso
hoy nuestro equipo está conformado por
alrededor de 160 personas 148 de ellas
están dentro de presión
350 mujeres
han tenido la disposición de aprender un
oficio
y de tener un ingreso alejado de la
delincuencia
esto con el tiempo lo fuimos
complementando con otras actividades
talleres de yoga meditación de
literatura escritura y sobre todo
talleres de salud mental
porque entendimos algo fundamental que
es que sólo lástima a aquel que está
profundamente herido
19 personas han salido ya de prisión 7
sigues trabajando con nosotros pero ya
en libertad otras han sido canalizadas
empleos formales
y algunas pues debemos confesarles
perdimos la pista o le pedimos el
contacto pero afortunadamente ninguna de
ellas nos hemos visto de vuelta en las
cuatro cárceles en las que trabajamos
ahora
lo que pudimos ver a partir de esta
experiencia un poco implementada pequeña
escala es lo mucho que puede contribuir
el trabajo y la labor remunerada a este
sentido de autosuficiencia de superación
personal
a la esperanza de poder ser reinsertar
más rápido de la sociedad
ellas descubrieron que tienen un talento
hay alguien que dice que ella no le pone
los ojos a los muñecos cuando está
triste porque no quiere mandar esa
tristeza al exterior que ya solo le
hacen los ojos cuando es un día feliz
porque quiere que la gente vea que su
muñeco está feliz
y además esto tiene un impacto de manera
indirecta a las familias que las visitan
o que éstas las dejaron de visitar a los
hijos que tal vez también dejaron afuera
porque hoy su expediente ya no habla
sólo de delincuencia habla de
responsabilidad habla de trabajo de
dedicación de trabajo en equipo habla de
estos productos increíbles que fabrican
como este que ven aquí que es la pérdida
frida la famosa frida rescatista que
como recordarán nos conmovió a todos en
el sismo del 2017
ellas donaron el producto de su trabajo
y lo que se ganó de las ventas sirvió
para reconstruir cinco hogares en la
sierra de oaxaca
lo que hicieron con eso y con sus manos
fue sanar y acompañar un poco del dolor
que quizás cinco familias tuvieron por
haber perdido sus hogares y sus casas
y la cana también nos ha permitido
conocer otras historias similares hace
algunos días conocí ha ayudado a varios
hombres que descubrieron dentro de la
cárcel su talento para escribir
y para actuar
tenían de todas las condenas desde 5
hasta 21 años
antes eran reconocidos por ser homicidas
narcomenudistas ladrones de autos
pero hoy son actores pintores artistas
recuerdo que le contaba esto un amigo y
me decía es que para ti es muy fácil
creer en eso porque nunca ha sido
víctima de la delincuencia
y quizás tenía razón
hasta que un día de regreso de comer con
mi familia
regresé a mi casa y encontramos a puerta
abierta
en cuestión de horas se habían llevado
cosas que quizás implicaban años de
esfuerzo de trabajo de dedicación
recuerda ese sentimiento de impotencia
de miedo de saber que unos desconocidos
habían entrado a mi casa y se habían
tomado la libertad de remover los
cajones donde tenía las cosas más
íntimas
remover mi espacio mi cuarto
y entonces recordé a mi amigo
y absolutamente todo eso sentido
porque entendí que las víctimas podemos
ser cualquiera de nosotros y lo que
tenemos que hacer es evitar que ese
sentimiento que seguramente en delitos
mayores es por mucho peor que ese
sentimiento nos alcanza a todos
y para eso hay que atender las causas y
por eso como sociedad necesitamos
voltear la mirada a ver qué sucede
dentro de nuestras cárceles
porque ahí existe una oportunidad
invaluable
aislar simplemente no va a estar
ahí existe la oportunidad de enseñarle a
las personas que por una u otra razón
llegaron hasta ahí que existen otras
posibilidades
ofrecerles
pues justo eso la posibilidad de ser
mucho más de lo que pareciera que están
destinados a ser solo por las
circunstancias
porque de lo contrario
tendríamos que reconocer que entonces
nuestras cárceles solo sirven como
jaulas humanas
y hay que recordar que la gran mayoría
de ellos estarán de regreso con nosotros
en la sociedad
y quizás están privados de la libertad y
eso implica que están privados de
algunos derechos pero todos todos
tenemos sueños y ellos también los
tuvieron antes de entrar
y lo que no podemos permitir es privar a
la gente de la oportunidad
de volver a empezar de corregir de
enmendar
de tomar otras armas de la educación
en el trabajo
del talento
desde la dedicación la de tener una vida
digna
porque al final
pues la vida es eso
y es tejer sueños desbordar historias es
aprender puntadas es cambiar de aguja
hilo
es desatar nudos
es avanzar en la labor deshacer errores
pero sobre todo
y más importante en la vida es volver a
empezar muchas gracias